in the first couple of years i was
everything i was writing the code i was
getting the customers i was
making the operations i was doing
everything
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford it's time to get inspired by
one of israel's leading entrepreneurs
meet hanameet co-founder and ceo of
tipalti
ken is a veteran high-tech executive and
repeat entrepreneur
prior to tipalti fenn was the ceo of
achrika
a carrier ethernet company that nokia
siemens acquired
before atrica chen was co-founder and
ceo of virix
a provider of business intelligence
software at eci telecom hen founded
their adsl business unit and led it from
inception to a hundred million dollars
in annual sales
he earned a bsc from the technion israel
institute of technology
and an mba from insead thank you for
joining me today how are you
great thank you for having me i am
honored to have a
one of israel's greatest inspirations
from the tech scene
uh with the an incredible journey all
the way from the telecom industry
to creating a huge streams of revenue to
the different
companies you've worked with all the way
now to co-founding tea party with
the amazing organization today running
this incredible incredible company
that is it seems to be doubling at an
incredible pace because as i was doing
research for this episode
i came across articles in every year by
a different publisher and every year you
seem to have doubled
you know the amount of transactions and
amount of employees so that literally
you know year-over-year growth but
before we get to all that ken
we have to talk about a few key things
first of all
2007-2008 making a living out of poker
it is a lifelong dream of mine
to compete and win in the world series
of poker i have to hear a little bit
about this
so um i sold a different company africa
to nokia siemens
at around that time and i had a year
to kill so so to speak between
selling in africa
and relocating back to israel um we were
living in california
and we planned to move back to israel in
the at the year
and actually was also starting some
software initiatives i had some ideas
for software around poker i was writing
some
some interesting poker software and then
for that year i made the yeah i made a
living
not like it's a modest living let's say
but yeah
i played poker uh for a living for a
year
and supported my family it's not enough
to feed my family but it was a positive
experience
i love that so mark your calendar in a
few years we're gonna meet each other at
table nine
at the world series event uh but before
that i also have to ask
about you know this you're practicing
snooker with the european champion
you're a private
pilot that flew over you know active
volcanoes i'm seeing a trend here of
doing you know these
extraordinary things and going deep into
them tell me a little bit about this
going deep into your hobbies because
you're not just scratching the surface
you really are going deep that's true
when i do something i'm kind of all in
i have a few hobbies that i rotate
between now in kovid i i
am leaning more towards snooker for
anyone in the u.s snooker is a form of
billiard that is
the the popular form in europe
so again when i moved back so i was
playing poker moved back to israel
in 2008 after a year
a friend invited me to play snooker at
some club
i played with him for a couple of years
and then i forget which birthday
but my wife arranged for me in our
practice with
he was the israeli champion at the time
he since
he won like five national championships
and last year he won one of the european
championships
so now weekly i i practice with him
and it's it's great you know what like
first of all you want a hobby
it allows you to kind of diffuse from
the day-to-day work
and also it's really great to to
challenge yourself snooker is really
hard
to challenge yourself and improve and
improve every time you improve you know
it feels you like
okay we made progress we made progress
we're now doing better and we're doing
better
so yeah it's a it's great
and flying flying was a passion since i
was a kid you know i was
like a teenager building model planes
and
subscribed to the aviation magazine and
all of that
but because at the time they weren't
taking people with
eyeglasses to um to the air force i i
couldn't even try
uh but in 2000 the first thing i did
after i left tci that telecommunications
company
the first thing i did literally the day
after was take
a flight lesson here near and near tel
aviv
and i flew with oren to
in mexico once like 17 i think
seven or eight hours i forget how many
but many maybe 17 hours
many a small airplane um
i went while watching with uh with those
small airplanes
and wow in hawaii i flew over the
volcano
and saw it burning red
incredible experiences and the main
inspiration i'm getting from this is
this idea of going deep
not not you know having enough of just
you know tasting it but
really really becoming a somewhat of an
expert and it sounds like you've become
somewhat of an expert
in all those domains but what's just as
interesting
is the fact that your hob your your
passion for diving deep into new
uncharted territories
it also sounds like that's almost the
journey to start the party right because
heavy into fintech you're not from
fintech
how how does that happen that you're
coming to disrupt an industry
that you don't really know too much
about
so you're right what attracted me
to this problem that that we're solving
was that i didn't know anything about it
right
because that's what's challenging that's
what's exciting to learn something new
and to be challenged and
so oren had a portfolio company
that was suffering from some
challenges around payments he introduced
me to the founder
and um and and that was the genesis a
founder that said i have a pain
please solve it for me initially i
thought it was going to be a project
um again at the time i was in between
like after africa like a year or so a
couple of
year and a half after i took i said you
know what uh
i really like programming i haven't
programmed for 17 years
but why don't i take it as a project and
see what i can do for this
founder and go back to programming i
really liked it it's like
for me programming is like problem
solving and riddles and
all of that so i went and built it for
that founder and
really shortly after found another
company with the same pain
a few years later we're processing 18
billion dollars we're 400
growing to almost 800 and
growing as you said not only doubling
year over year but accelerating our
growth five years in a row so
that that that is unbelievable so walk
me a little bit through the
the ten years you mentioned to me that
you know every year is
its own journey and it's its own world
that we can spend hours talking about so
i'd love to hear a little bit you know
from the founders perspective
growing from a project to a you know an
18 billion dollar transactional year
project
it's not so much of a project anymore
but how do you
how do you make that transition from a
project to okay we're actually going to
build this into
a real company yeah
i my role really changes every
i want to say 18 months or so at this
pace at the pace we grow
my role actually changes every 18 months
in the
first couple of years i was everything i
was writing the code i was getting the
customers i was
making the operations i was doing
everything
then we started slowly to build the
company
and the role changes uh every every few
you know every 18 months or so in 2017
we made a conscious decision that this
is not growth pivot
we're switching gears fundraising and
accelerating our go-to-market engine
and everything happened since when you
see all this doubling
growing accelerating growth here over
here it's
the result of that decision that we are
there's product market fit there's a
product
if there's a market we need to go after
a and accelerate it
we're now at the at the most recent
junction i don't know how many junctions
there were but we're now at the junction
where
we're growing from we were 280 people
at the beginning of 2020 which is still
manageable i still hired the vast like
about a third of the company i met
during the hiring process
many others i was you know i met in
other
situations by now when we're 400 and
we're hiring
almost 400 this year so will be 800 by
the end of the year
the company is now changing now it's not
as if everyone
met me and heard me in person
and they know what we're going where
we're going and why we're going there
and
you know they it's the alignment needs
to be more structured
and communication needs to be more
structured and
you need to be clear with your
vision with your strategy with your uh
plans so that everyone is aligned
everyone's going in the same direction
and that that word that is used
often culture really means something you
really need to invest in the culture
that culture that we've built over 10
years now you need to be very
you know in two years time that team
that we had at the beginning of 2020
will only be a quarter of the team
because we're growing so fast
there will be a minority so if you want
to retain your culture and we do
you need to invest in it and to be
mindful about
so what does that actually mean to
invest in it because on one hand you can
be as intentional as you want about
about the hiring about the people
you can be as intentional as you want
about the vision of the company
but how did the end do you maintain this
sense of the te culture
trying to maintain as much as it was in
the beginning that made it so successful
as you're literally doubling the company
right
yeah yeah so there it's not one thing
you need
you need to do a lot of things that will
eventually translate
into a that culture being
maintained it starts with hiring you
need to hire
the right people for your culture and
you need to correct
a hiring if you made a mistake and it
starts with the top
i need to hire executives who are
really reflecting the culture of the
rest of the team
and then they need to hire and we need
to
talk about it and make sure that we hire
the second levels and so on and so forth
um when you see you need to talk about
the culture you need people need to
understand what's important for us
and how do we take decisions and what is
acceptable and what is not acceptable
um so culture is not about but but
i'll correct myself culture is not so
much about talking
culture is mostly about doing you need
to
talk to walk the talk and
if if um if you
see a good things that reflect your
culture
amplify them recognize them you know
elevate them if you see things that are
contradicting to the culture
or helping the culture make it very
clear that you're correcting it and that
it's unacceptable
and as long as you do that and in a
respectable way
people will appreciate that and um i
think that's that's
culture i can't even imagine you know
the difficulty and the
you know the the craziness of growing a
team
almost pretty much doubling year over
year and
just as the team is doubling also the
what the company is doing is
increasing right the engagement is
increasing the market leadership is
increasing
your responsibility to navigate through
the
fintech world is changing talk to me a
little bit about what the party actually
does today
and a little bit about this industry and
and the gap that you found that
today you're solving for over a thousand
customers i believe
yeah um so possibly the last part
of the uh a
finance stack to be automated is the
around accounts payable
in the accounts payable especially in
the mid market and in fast growing
companies
it's not where your typical ceo likes to
invest
resources and time suppliers
paying suppliers who cares right who
really really cares
the only one the only ones who really
care is the party
we really really care and that's why we
have a business
because we care and we help our
customers who really want to do
something else
they don't it's not i'm exaggerating
when i say they don't care they care
but they want to invest the precious
resources
in the product in the service in
expansion
in net promoter score in whatever a key
metric
that is hardcore to their success
these are the prime priorities for them
if we can
take a very cumbersome error-prone
risky process remove it off their table
will do wonders to their ability to
continue execute
in the places where they really need and
that's what we do so we automate
that and and unfortunately accounts
payable
is not one thing it's dozens
of things it's onboarding suppliers it's
tax
it's anti-money laundry it's currencies
it's payments it's supply
chain finance it's invoices really it's
crazy
these are that's the challenge the
challenge is that you have
a broad set of discrete functions that
you need to deliver
to a cfo or vp finance that doesn't have
a moment to spare you cannot make it too
complex for them
need to be it needs to be simple it
needs to
implement quickly and just take away all
the
other challenge but the more complex
uh it is to deliver great service to
a customer the better we are because
we've invested
so many years in building a really
robust really broad
solution that does all of these things
that i mentioned from supply onboarding
vetting tax compliance currency
management payments invoices all of that
so we are a holistic solution for the
whole payable automation
on a global basis layer in global
layering cross-border regulators from
120 countries
have fun it's a it's an exciting time
i love that going back to this the
founding and
you meeting the founder understanding
there's a gap taking on this project
that turns into
the the incredible being that the
incredible entity that is the faulty
today
what role did it play because you're
saying the words simple
quick and seamless all in the context of
fintech in the context of finance and
cfo
that doesn't go hand in hand in my mind
so obviously you're onto something here
but
what i'm curious about is how big of a
role did your
sort of i guess humbleness or you know
innocence coming into the industry how
did that play a role because a lot of
people talk about
you know in order to really disrupt an
industry you have to be somewhat of an
outsider to it
absolutely absolutely uh
we weren't the first in the market
there are a couple of competitors that
were in the market
let's say 10 years before we started and
and
by the way we've met them we've
discussed what we're going through
at least some of them in the first year
i met them i discussed what i'm going to
do
they gave me a thumbs up yeah go ahead
and do that
but since they were so so ingrained in
what they were doing in their own way of
doing business
they didn't even see that that
that it's just you need to look at it
this way not that way you know it's just
a different perspective on the problem
and
yeah for me for me it was really simple
i sat with
the founder of that company i knew
nothing i know nothing about
payments tax compliance ml compliance
currencies i know nothing about that
these are some of the set of challenges
he was speaking with so i sat with him
in a session i asked okay can i join you
and see how your day that payment day
here the two payment days a month
how your payment day looks like except
within four hours
was ridiculous it was so funny
that it was obvious that there was
something to do here and then
i i thought then i spent a couple of
months thinking
okay so what's what's the right approach
how do i
i do that and i started sketching the
mock-up
and shared it with the two now i had
already the two cfos
and they gave me feedback and
by the way some of the feedback i took
and
corrected uh what my design some of the
feedback i'm really proud to
reject it and it was it was a
feedback that that one of the executives
they're not not the two founders but one
another executive told me you have to do
it this way
or else there's no way we'll adopt it
but i understood that he's
missing the big picture i did it
differently
and and it was critical
still is critical to our success
so he wanted a faster horse and you
wanted to build a car
yeah yeah he wanted you're right
he wanted a faster horse it's exactly
that he didn't
know what he didn't know yeah right i
love that
and ken you've reached a stage i believe
you said in 2017 that junction of
transitioning from product market fit
search to
the growth so you you obviously you
reach the point where
you know every startup you know dreams
to get to where they're so confident
that they found product market fed their
customers are happy and they're able to
make that transition
was that easy was that obvious when you
found product market fit
because i can't imagine it being you
know one day a light bulb says okay now
we're ready
now we have product market fit how do
you even determine that
it was like that it was now it was like
that
one day we said okay tomorrow is growth
uh but obviously it was true for
probably
six or nine months earlier right it
wasn't at that point in time
it's a it was more complex 2017 was a
complex year for us
we had a were fundraising then we had an
acquisition
interest then we were fundraising again
and through all these processes
at the second fundraising we said okay
why are we fundraising
we need to move faster we need to move
faster what are we waiting for
what is it for really that was the
discussion between
myself what is it to wait for anymore
we have retention in the quality is
ridiculous like
customer retention and equality is the
best not in the industry
to my knowledge in the world we have 99
gross dollar retention 134 net
orientation i don't know of any other
company
that on an annual basis loses one
percent
of the value of its customers through
churn so we had that all along
it was you know if it wasn't one it was
two we had
great uh retention we had great
expansion
we had great unit economics
why wait what's what this there was
nothing
there was no additional milestone to
reach now it was about execution
so once we've had this discussion it was
i'm describing it
in in it took less time to make the
discussion decide on it
than what i just did it took us five
minutes to say okay why would you
fundraising what there is is there to
wait for
let's go so yeah what i love about these
stories
is you know from as a young entrepreneur
on the sidelines you know sometimes you
go i go to you know
a stanford business school class and i
read a case study about all these
different considerations
should they do this should they do this
they sit for months and they deliberate
and
there is no right and then you see you
know a unicorn
ceo of a unicorn coming in saying you
know really the decision to
take that light so i did once we had
that right discussion
it was obvious and we made the decision
we moved quickly and i just love that
because it brings it down to reality
and and i just love the journey thank
you so much for spending your time with
me i know how busy you are and i so so
appreciate it
i love teapot i love what you're doing
there and it's just an inspiring journey
all around
before we leave i have to ask the most
important question
which is three words that you which you
would choose to describe yourself or if
i would ask
anybody in tipalti how would they
describe hanamit
well it's two different things how i
would i would describe myself and others
would describe me i think i will i think
the one
the overlap would be limited i'm sorry
um
how i would describe myself um
simple slash humble right um i may i
like to keep things simple and
i don't hold myself too seriously i
don't hold the company like
i hold the company but but if people
make
too much like we're serving a market
we're selling building a product
but let's be serious we're we're uh
let's not
build uh our egos more than more than
they should right we are
we're here we're working together we're
building something so
keep it real um
[Music]
one of the execs uh told me that one of
my management tools is humor and i think
that's true
i think i i use humor and
um i go deep as you said earlier
i go deep i i know how to play the
strategic level
but i can also go very deep and um
you know if i need to uh and oren also
says that i'm even kill that i'm not
easily rattled like no high highs no low
lows
and kind of uh balance even kids
yeah i love it this was wonderful i'll
see you at the final table at the wsop
in a few years
and until then i can't wait to keep
following the journey
take care thank you for having me